To show you why Numpy and
pandas are useful.
I'm going to revisit some
code from last lesson, and
see how it would look if
I wrote it using pandas.
This is the code to first take a CSV and
read it into a list, and
then get the unique
accounts out of that list.
I'm running this code on
the daily engagement full file,
since that file is rather large, and
pandas deals with large files nicely.
Now if I run the code to load the file
into a CSV, it takes a little while and
finally it finished.
Now, we cut some of the loading
time out of the video, but
it took about one minute.
Then after that, getting the unique
students takes a little while as well.
In fact, this one is going to take
about six seconds, and now we're done.
As you'll see in a minute,
when I use pandas,
the code will run much more quickly.
In fact, in pandas this will also
be only three lines of code.
The first will be this import statement.
In the second, I'll read it in the file
using pandas built-in read CSV function.
And, finally, I can specify that I
want to look at the acct column.
And then use pandas built-in unique
function to get the unique accounts.
As you can see, pandas has a lot of
convenient functions, like read CSV and
unique, that previously
we had written ourselves.
Now of these three lines of code, the
one that actually takes the longest for
me is importing pandas, which takes
several seconds the first time I do it.
That is certainly very long for
just importing a library.
But it more than makes up for it with
the speed of the rest of the code.
After that, reading the data into
the CSV takes just a few seconds,
rather than the one minute
that I waited earlier.
And actually getting the unique accounts
finishes before I can even blink.